on le sait un grand pouvoir implique de
grandes responsabilités mais dans le
monde politique
un grand pouvoir semble surtout
impliquer une grande libido l'affairé
actuelle autour de benjamin griveaux qui
secoue la classe politique en rappel
beaucoup d'autres si on sait que chirac
était un véritable croqueur de femmes
les scandales sexuels ou les histoires
intimes de nos responsables politiques
font régulièrement la une de l'actualité
on se souvient bien sûr en 2011 de l'
affaire dsk qui avait défrayé la
chronique en raison de l'agression
supposée de nafissatou diallo au sofitel
de new york
elle dit avoir été agressée sexuellement
dans la suite
28/06 celle du patron du fmi
une affaire qui en avait amené une autre
avec le scandale des prostituées du
carlton de lille françois hollande a lui
aussi été épinglé par la presse à cause
d'une relation intime alors qu'il était
encore officiellement au couple avec
valérie trierweiler l'ancien président
avait été pris en flagrant délit
d'adultère avec la crise julie gayet ces
photos ont provoqué la colère de
françois hollande histoire secrète
révélait également du côté de françois
mitterrand avec sa fille mazarine né
d'une relation adultérine qu'entretenait
le président avec l'historienne anne
pingeot la presse mettra plus de 19 ans
a révélé l'existence de cette fille
cachée des petites histoires qui font la
grande et qui montre bien la relation
complexes qu'entretiennent les hommes
politiques avec leur intimité alors
scandales sexuels en politique la
république est elle en danger
alors c'est vrai qu'il ya plein de
choses hein c'est vrai qu'ils sortent
c'est vrai qu'il ya des trucs
incroyables
on va faire le point sur la sphère
griveaux qui sous-entend laissez-vous de
la faim griveaux laurent c est ce que
vous êtes étonné je suis pas étonné
parce que pas étonné que ça a été
publiée que ce soit resté longtemps mais
après que cette vidéo existe chez pas
étonné parce que un homme politique ça
reste un homme et donc quand on rentre
en politique on rentre pas au couvent
quand qu'on a les mêmes faiblesses ses
choix dans le monde politique ou pas
plutôt oui
ah ouais sur quoi disons qu il est aussi
globalement les mecs ils se passent
normalement ils n'ont pas de temps pour
aller ça peut aller vite
ben cinq minutes douche comprise oui je
cherche par exemple
ah oui elles ne sont pas plus long
d'accord peut-être parfois c'est plus
souvent mais c'est pas plus longtemps
mais que les hommes et les femmes
politiques aussi les la politique en
général enfin déjà le pouvoir attire
déjà la réalité c'est que il ya déjà
plus d'occasions si on veut dire des
choses comme ça c'est l'île de la
tentation
maintenant bientôt les les ministres
arrivés sur d autres à l'elysée sur le
perron et là y'a des matins
selon faut dire la vérité parce que si
on fait croire que par qu'on fait de la
politique on rentre au couvent et qu'on
fait un voeu de chasteté ou à votre
fidélité c'est pas vrai c'est pas parce
qu'on fait de la politique que vous êtes
fidèles et ses accès libre parole des
républiques à ce que vous feriez
beaucoup draguer parce que vous êtes
très joli merci pour le compliment je me
faisais un peu draguer pas trop un peu
beaucoup
moi j'avais des techniques pour éviter
les problèmes c'est quoi la chine par
exemple si vous êtes dans un bureau
politique on vous envoie un sms un peu
coquin mais quand vous sortez vous allez
voir la personne devant tout le monde et
puis vous lui dites merci pour ton
message est très sage et adoré par
contre j'ai jamais balancé ce qu'on m'a
envoyé parce que quand on vous envoie
quelque chose des personnes vous fait
confiance
vous avez reçue en don sinon je lui
écris et vendredi pour le souhait pour
le photon du genre de grimm a pas
répondu alors je sais pas sous quelle
forme il peut me répondre mais pour moi
il m'a pas répondu
alors oui je le plains non mais c'est je
le plains je l'avais jean-michel serrés
que c'est pas nouveau que le sexe est
quelque chose de très cérébral et les
femmes sont plus en plus absurde
sexuelle et qu'elles sont atterrés a le
plus attiré par l'intelligence que par
le physique contrairement aux hommes bon
qu'un homme politique ce sont des bêtes
d'intelligence ils sont très rapides et
très cdc des mecs cdd m et du coup mais
les femmes sont très attirées le
physique ne compte pas forcément c'est
un sac déguisant comme dsk etc qui sont
pas le physique n'est pas leur meilleur
atout à toutes les femmes étaient
complètement attiré comme attiré comme
un moustique par la lumière et draguer
par un homme politique ou une femme
politique jean-michel à moi non plus pas
plus dragué parlera pas une femme
politique mais en revanche je
connaissais des gens assez news ou comme
les hommes politiques venaient toutes
heures pour les interviews ou même ceux
dont pensée qui pouvait leur donner le
la bénédiction comme ça glisse et des
motifs des mines et des billets que leur
numéro de téléphone aux hôtesses aux
personnes qui étaient qui est à
l'accueil de ces news alors des
scandales sexuels avec des politiques en
a eu plein bien entendu le plus élèves
c'est la sphère de vie de dsk
christophe combarieu qui éclatent au
grand jour le 14 mai 2011 c'est le plus
gros scandale alors qu'il est le
président du fonds monétaire
international et qu'une rumeur le
présente comme un potentiel candidat à
l'élection présidentielle
dominique strauss kahn est accusé
d'avoir violé une femme dans un hôtel à
new york et je vous dis tout le monde
disait à l'époque dsk il est hyper chaud
et irak tout le monde et nous dire la
vérité parce que ça aussi c'est comme
dans le patinage il ya plein de gens qui
l'ont dit après moi mais tout le monde
savait je regarde la fosse kahn inculpé
d'agression et de tentative de viol
aurait nié tous les faits qui lui sont
reprochés
hier dans l'après midi une jeune femme
de chambre du sofitel de manhattan
or et appelé la police au secours elle
dit avoir été agressée sexuellement dans
la suite 28,06 celle du patron du fmi il
serait sorti nu de sa salle de bains
aurait bouclé la porte avant d'abuser
d'elle à plusieurs reprises alors et
c'est quand même incroyable c'est que
dsk est quand même le mentor de benjamin
griveaux c'est quand même allégé la
pression on l'appelle alors mais ça tout
le monde dit que ton vous le savez tout
ça parce que les hommes politiques
pourquoi on dit voilà que les hommes
politiques c'est la question qu'on peut
ce soir sont obsédés par le sexe
bah je pense que ce sont des êtres
humains comme les autres est ce que
pourquoi ils disent qu'ils n'auraient
pas le droit d'être obsédé par le sexe
comme tout le monde
comme tout le monde mais comme oreiller
sont plus exposés et qu'on dirait on se
dit qu'ils n'ont pas le droit
ça ça ressort plus alors ils ont par
moments ils ont envie d'être comme tout
le monde et puis et puis j'aime bien
s'apparenter aujourd'hui maintenant il
ya des chaînes d'info ou sont sur les
plateaux sans arrêt ils s'apparentent à
des stars aussi donc il faut avoir le
revers de la médaille on a envie de voir
les seins de sophie marceau n'a envie de
voir la conquête d'un patrick bruel
l'essence a fait savoir s'y attendait
quand un art c'est mal me siens de
qualification ils sont passionnés quand
vous êtes passionné en fait vous avez
plus de libido c'est ça la libido
vous êtes passionné vous prenez des
risques vous êtes toujours
l'hyperactivité l'hyper action donc en
fait vous consommez quoi et vous croquer
le cours de l'once d'or qui s'ignorent
du zèle le pouvoir et le plus puissant
des aphrodisiaques
c'est vrai je vous dis pourquoi je vous
dis ça parce que on va voir la
déclaration de potes d'autres provinces
qui t'ai fait qu'ils avaient mis les
vidéos de benjamin griveaux qui juste
après de sortie du bureau du juge
alors qu'il vient d'apprendre qu'il est
mis en examen regardez il dit qu'il a
énormément de jeu seulement deux
commandes ce nouveau projet pour nos
politiques c'est mon nouveau projet et
j'espère que je pourrai continuer parce
que après troisième joueur c'est ce
trajet pour honorer son célèbre ok c'est
pas vraiment de ce monstre en situation
parce que je pensais que française ces
pays de liberté de l'expression
alors ce qui est oui pour revenir sur
dsk il était hyper protégé faire que des
médias savait mais il y avait une
protection autour de lui et des médias
n'ont pas osé et d'ailleurs là non plus
avec la sphère padres qui les médias
traditionnels n'ont pas osé celle
maintenant la fuite vers les réseaux
sociaux qui va faire tout exploser
jean-michel argileux tu dis tu librement
des bêtises les risques et les légendes
savez on savait qu'ils étaient libertin
qu'il aimait bien les cinq fonds n'avait
jamais fait d'agression sexuelle avant
excuse-moi faso fait suite à des
informations donc évidemment quand tu
sais des choses sur la la la la vérité
celle de quelqu'un doit partir
d'abord il ya un livre qui est sorti il
ya quelques jours l'ancien chauffeur de
jacques chirac a fait des révélations
étonnantes
il explique qu'il a vu des femmes
politiques avoir des relations intimes
avec l'ancien président elle avait le
chemisier déboutonnée et de fines
gambettes guinée de bas nylon c'était
une femme politique connue aux mains
baladeuses mais pas que on peut dire que
je me suis bien c'est l'oeil
le chauffeur de jacques chirac mal
acquis qui disent ah c'est vrai qu'il ya
valéry giscard d'estaing aussi qui a été
président de 60 01 80 qui lui aussi
était réputé pour être un gros dragueur
alors comme ça il n'y a pas les reins
bouchard avec lui normalement le bras
voilà tout côtoie mais non ils avaient
ils avaient d'ailleurs une rumeur qui
disait qu'il avait pécho lady di c'était
devenu un sketch culte longer voilà
sans foie rein damon bonjour veaux
[Musique]
vaches asseoir dessus
ayew ça fait tout drôle à la 110e cochon
là
merde encore raté le me [ __ ] à côté
d'elle pendant le dîner
et moi alors je garde
josh et n'ont donc pas de moi ont la
garde
j'ai rencontré didier cette semaine à
paris et vous de l'aîné j'avais conclure
la manche a même tellement échelle
après faire les bouffer qu'une bande de
vieux grigou qu'on connaît même pas
alors que moi j'ai pas réparer le
terrain par le concert le méthane ok
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai que on a l'impression que les
hommes politiques ils veulent faire
aussi des beaux gosses long sagaie dire
alors qu'on pète tout ça oui parce que
déjà le faire de la politique c'est
séduire une façon on est toujours dans
la séduction que ce soit la séduction
intellectuelle ou physique
donc ça amène déjà ça et puis après
alors il faut faire la différence entre
ce qui est consenti qu'est ce qu'il
n'est pas et ça c'est très important
les agressions sexuelles bien sûr faut
les condamner et ensuite qui est
consentie mais il faut l'admettre parce
que ça sert à rien les nouvelles sans
citer de ce que vous avez assisté à des
scènes voilà dans le monde politique
séché nantes oui parfois vous pouvez
voir sortir des bureaux des gens un peu
ébouriffé ou dans les ascenseurs que les
gens s'écartent en effet quelques-uns
nous en effet quelques-uns
oui non mais j'ai déjà sorti aucun homme
politique juste devant laquelle
s'enduire de la théorie c'est justement
de dire que la vie privée doit rester
privé n'est pas ici pendant tes pump et
non mais vous avez ça veut dire oui
c'est à dire oui oui oui c'est vrai
qu'une sextape
[Rires]
j'ai posé qui suit on est sur les
politiques gentilles obsédé par le sexe
so what you say vidéo pourquoi celles
consenties l'avait déjà fait une sextape
c'est consenti c'est chiant je m'en
souviens pas mais dans le doute je ne
répondrai pas on sait jamais parce que
si un jour il
j'ai pour atteindre soir dire quoi que
ce soit diffusé là évidemment que les
vidéos qui peuvent sortir ce quand
quelqu'un moi j'ai déjà été une soirée
où il y avait des sk foot et une soirée
un peu coquine voilà et je peux vous
dire que là il a agressé personne gilles
bertine sur une péniche à paris
et toutes les femmes était attiré par
lui le nous a évidemment quand vous
savez que vous allez peut-être mes shows
dsk vous demandez un copain ou une
copine de filmer parce que c'est pas le
tout les jours donc il ya peine vidéos
qui vont sortir
et puis je pense que le la révélation de
table ce qui va va appeler forcément
d'autres révélations de non pas parce
que lui a pas forcément des dossiers sur
plein de monde mais je pense que plein
de gens dont le contact est maintenant
lui en faire 10 dans les bennes est
sacré meilleur sur la vidéo et les
autres exemples qu'on a alors il y en à
mitterrand bien sûr un mitterrand est en
danger dans ces urnes enfant caché
pendant des années il a reconnu
l'existence de sa fille très tard suite
à un article de presse
donc ça c'était vraiment c'est un
exemple incroyable oui ça existe depuis
toujours en fait depuis la nuit des
temps jules césar il avait une
réputation de collectionneurs napoléon
et du reggae il est au moins ils
envoyaient l'on parle pas de deux du
choix c'est sexuel par pareil pour
napoléon il envoyait talleyrand pour
chercher une maîtresse pour chaque soir
on a vu aussi henri calef et le mignon
le giga lan berlusconi enfin il y en a
plein
bien ok mais gfk c'était était un obsédé
sexuel comme charles de gaulle à mai sur
la séduction et les hommes politiques je
suis désolé mais que dans toutes les
rédactions paris match les des magazines
généralistes paris match vsd
on en voyait faire les hommes politiques
est revenu et les hommes politiques des
jeunes filles dont moi qui n'avait
aucune légitimité politique à le faire
sans cage et qu'ils étaient des guitares
nom que lui même sans le même sens
couché avec la jeune fille qu'ils
allaient être amenées pour se vanter à
lui dire des choses que des journalistes
plus expérimenté mais moins appétissante
n'obtiendrait pas il te visiter les
magnifiques et sérieuse même si ces
massifs des mouches et de la plaquette
vapona c'est je vais pouvoir désormais
jeune fille s'imaginent qu'ils sont
beaux et c'est sous le thème sapin qui
disait depuis qu'il est ministre il se
retrouve dans ses bulls voilà oui
environ 7 à 17 ans que les problèmes
d'ailleurs avec l'industrie cnegi kwakwa
sapin qui a eu des problèmes d'ailleurs
appliqué depuis le fils arrachés quand
elle est passée du de leur mari pour
nous raconter c'est quoi non il a été un
peu oui
il a été accusé d'avoir alors le string
je ne suis qui passait par là mais c'est
un peu bouché
installant sur noir et les prénoms sont
changés même peut-être parfois à
l'extrême
alors bien sûr c'est très positif bien
sûr parce qu'il faut pas oublier quand
même que dans toutes ces jeunes femmes
ou jeunes hommes souvent ben c'est des
gens qui sont soumis hiérarchiquement et
donc sont obligés donc à ces très graves
et donc là on a enlevé quand même un
procédé qui étaient condamnables
néanmoins sacré quand même des tensions
même entre gens qui seraient
éventuellement consentants ça crée des
tensions parce que les uns les autres
n'osent plus trop les hommes d'être plus
vous faire des compliments et est-ce que
c'était très chaud à une époque c'était
plus chaud à l'époque fallait génération
à moi la mienne je pense parce que les
hommes étaient encore plus dans ce tout
pouvoir
mais comment il faut pour voilà et
caisses quand ils font les l'aider un
peu parce qu'on a vu hollande qui
s'était s'était sauvé en scooter comment
ils font pour aller c'est tout le
problème chez demos est en fait plus
vous exposer plus c'est difficile
d'avoir une maîtresse ou un amant bien
sûr sauvegardées castle et donc c'est
parfait
mais là n'est pas sa vie privée encore
mais c'est pour ça qu'en fait certains
privilégient des relations à distance en
pensant que c'est plus sécurisés
notamment
c'est à dire téléphone par exemple mais
là je vois pas en disant qu'au moins on
va pas les voir en disant qu'il ya des
moyens d'effacer les écrans souvent
quand on fait des captures d'écran on
l'a dit donc bouclé ses listes au milieu
c'est plus chaud dans la politique ou en
télévision
c'est pareil quoi et de manière générale
à porter du noir un nom mais à partir du
moment où il ya de la pression ou les
gens en son temps en relation
bon je sais pas c'est à vous de répondre
mieux que moi vous allez entre la
politique et la télé c'est qu'il faut
chausser paris la politique c'est quand
même plutôt langue parce que ya cette
idée de pouvoir et d'hommes de pouvoir
notamment mais vous savez dans la nature
la femelle est attiré par le mâle
dominant
on peut raconter ce qu'on veut mais un
homme politique est un mâle dominant il
attire les femelles route alain de le
dire mais comme je suis une femme c'est
plus facile et c'est vrai qu'à beaucoup
de femmes qui sont attirées par le
pouvoir donc ces hommes-là le savent ils
se disent de toute façon elle est à moi
je les ai donc du coup bah ils ont
beaucoup d'occases et donc beaucoup
d'histoires faute
il ya des femmes qui viendrait pas comme
ça te te voir à chaque fois aussi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est le mâle dominant vous êtes un mâle
dominant absolument oui je suis parent
légal et non non non non jamais tan
attributs du pouvoir alors pas que le
pouvoir politique le pouvoir aussi
médiatique sportive le cinéma la musique
effectivement vous rejoins vous étiez je
sais pas caissier par exemple mais avec
moins de succès et encore tous les
hommes politiques draguer en fait la
réponse est partout parce que moi je me
suis fait braquer par un homme politique
et à l'époque qu'il était ministre avec
un très haut placé de league one
oui on toujours de ce monde c'est
françois fillon
[Rires]
à venir etc
m
c'est vrai
spectacle de fin d'année déconne
enfin american il était à côté de sa
femme n'avaient pénélope qui étaient là
et qu'il regardait et d'ailleurs
franchement c'est que pénélope avait
l'oeil sur le dossier et regardait quand
même avec beaucoup beaucoup d'insistance
je sais pas je ne sais pas je peux pas
me prononcer parce que j'y suis pas allé
évidemment mais peut-être que si j'étais
allé non là ça aurait été votre sillon
non non merci les très belles autour
d'une part il est bas l'homme il a
beaucoup sex-appeal un proto lola nom de
sex apeal françois fillon mais le débit
il est quand même c'est un vrai fillon
ne respectent rien et 9 qui est attiré
par françois fillon qui l'homme
politique qui a le plus la cote
il avait arrêté à bas obama non les en
france aussi je n'ai madonna c'est tout
non seulement il essaie d'arracher des
succès les hommes et les hommes
politiques les hommes quand il est
président des ja la côte
non non vous êtes en train de me dire
que françois
[Rires]
au matin
ah ah